in uganda everyone knows they're going
to the polls
the signs are all around and everyone
knows who's likely to win it
at least officially
[Music]
the country's long-term president yuari
museveni
has the biggest billboards the deepest
pockets
and the machinery of state working for
him
the riot police and the military have
made life difficult for uganda's
opposition groups
party members and their leaders like
former pop star bobby wine
have been attacked and arrested
now i'm being arrested
and they're losing their ability to
communicate as well
president museveni has blocked all
social media platforms
he's unhappy that facebook deleted
accounts that were pushing
pro-government propaganda
the government has closed the social
media
there's no no way anybody can come and
play around with our
our our country to decide who is good
who is bad this one
will stop this one you cannot accept
that
taking on genome 70 is uh
taking on the uganda police force the
uganda military
the bank of uganda all institutions of
state have been deployed against us
we found the country's best-known
opposition leader
in a pensive mood as he circled the
garden on his property
bobby wine told us that 92 polling
agents
from his national unity platform have
been arrested
this week they are calling us informing
us of our agents being arrested
and those coordinators are being picked
up by the military and they're being
charged
with recruiting rebels so our polling
agents are being called rebels
that is a situation in uganda the 38
year old musician
who was raised in a slum has given
museveni a run for his money
but the insurgent candidate does not
expect the president
to go quietly i just wonder what do you
foresee over the next
two or three days well
we are already seeing the events
unfolding
as you must have seen the military has
been
heavily deployed with heavy
uh combat weapons
um as if the nation of uganda is under
attack by ana foreign aggressor
do you expect more violence of course we
expect more violence
but again we expect more resistance
bobby wine says he and his supporters
have put the president
on notice and an anxious nation awaits
the result
john sparks sky news kampala